okay I need to talk about something very
serious and also time-sensitive the
entire revelation that Russia acted to
help Donald Trump and hurt Hillary
Clinton in the november eighth election
via the hacking that they that we now
know they did of not only DNC computers
but RNC computers this is opening up
many new doors to pension potentially
stopping Donald Trump from assuming the
presidency on january twentieth and some
social media users have started to send
me uh the phone numbers of various state
attorneys general urging people to
contact them and request that the
electoral college voters be delayed in
casting their votes until all
investigations of russian hacking have
been concluded however here is where it
gets really interesting there's at least
one court decision which suggests that
there is actually some federal authority
to invalidate the election outcome after
the fact there is a political writer and
commentator who put an article together
on huffington post named alex major i
hope that's the right pronunciation of
alex's name and alex writes about a 1995
federal court ruling out of pennsylvania
which might provide the legal authority
for actually pulling an elected official
out of office and replacing them with
their former opponent in 1995 the united
states supreme court let stand a federal
district judge's ruling in pennsylvania
which invalidated a state senate
election because of fraud and this up
led to the judge ordering the winner be
removed and the vacancy to be filled by
their opponent this is mark's versus
stinson in 1994 what happened was that a
Democratic senator died and they held a
special election the special election
was Republican Bruce marks versus
Democrat William Stinson Stinson one and
were sort of using that term loosely one
but later massive fraud was uncovered
and in February of 94 after Stinson had
already taken office a federal judge
ordered that he be removed from his
state Senate office and that his
opponent be certified the winner within
72 hours
and appealed to the US Court of Appeals
for the cert Third Circuit ultimately uh
that this was upheld uh and the US
Supreme Court in January of 1995 allowed
that ruling to stand how it would apply
here well if after Donald Trump assumes
office it is determined that Russian
hacking or any fraud for that matter Rob
Hillary Clinton of her presidency there
would be at least one case we could
point to to say hey you know what courts
have the authority to say Trump out and
Clinton in if this reached the Supreme
Court however Pat remember what's
happening on the Supreme Court we've
been wondering whether that for for
split in the absence of a replacement to
the late Justice Antonin Scalia who
could have an impact we now have one
scenario in which that for four split
could have an impact yeah I mean I find
a little tough to believe that a special
election from a 1995 state Senate race
would be precedent for something as big
as a presidential election yeah but we
have seen the Supreme Court get
political before yep no further than
Bush versus Gore in two thousand and if
it was a much more liberal Supreme Court
than we have now that could sway the
election yeah I mean obviously it's not
looking good it's a very very
interesting article but we have a
situation here where if it was
determined that this 1994 election in
1995 supreme court case was relevant
precedent to what is going on now in
connection to the Russia investigation
and if it went all the way up to the
Supreme Court we have a Supreme Court
right now that would likely not be
particularly favorable but President
Obama can announce that he is putting
Merrick garland on the Supreme Court he
could do this tomorrow he would be able
to do that for a period not longer than
a year and that could potentially have
an impact here but we're thinking now
Pat like four or five steps ahead and I
can tell from your demeanor you don't
think this is going anywhere I don't
think the Republican Senate's going to
pass Merrick garland at this late stage
of his presence no but President Obama
can circumvent that and just appoint him
really yet he can skip that in it it
would last up to a year it's not
something that he is indicated he's
going to do I've said from the beginning
Merrick garland is a sort of sacrificial
lamb but that is something that he could
do he could just appoint Merrick garland
there and
skip the entire process but it would
only be a temporary appointment no
indication but President Obama plans to
do this send me your thoughts on this I
don't know there are too many in our
audience who see this is a likely
scenario but interesting nonetheless